we first saw you on an X Factor so you  come from that world of competition  television we just saw what happened  with Christina Grimmie the contestant  from The Voice does it make you think  now did you really have to watch those  fan interactions that you would do  things differently at meet and greets  after shows I had an experience kind of  having a someone come to a book signing  and attack me so I've had that  experience I still go out and do meet  and greets I still love to meet my fans  I still love to have that one-on-one  interaction with them and I would never  let anything stop me from doing that so  it's horrible and it's so so sad about  what happened and just my heart goes out  to her her family her friends for me I  just keep pushing through it and I still  you know that's a one in a million I'm  running a billion so you have to keep  you know have faith in people I think  you know